well I've been I've been really
fascinated by the life that you guys
live in Hawaii then it's because I've
always had this like idealized I'd like
one day like come but move to the Big
Island just chill on the side of a
mountain stop fucking around fly out to
do gigs but live out there where
everything's just more relaxed yeah you
know is it okay you know there's a lot
going on and like the Big Island is
obviously big city yeah no one's big
yeah it's sort of like LA on the beach
but you know there's a couple things I
think because it is a primal environment
like we live on kawaii which is pretty
heavy-duty as far as it's quiet there's
not a lot of distraction there's a
really heavy-duty nature and and so and
I grew up in in st. Thomas on the Virgin
Island so I was used to kind of being on
an island but you're you're with
yourself a lot so if you have things to
do that are you know productive then
it's perfect but what you have to always
calibrate is like the downtime or it
like it's been raining off and on for
like over a year on Hawaii whoa yeah so
after a while it'd be like Seattle in
that way where people it starts getting
heavy but it's sunny too right it can be
and that's the weirdest thing about the
islands yeah that there's different
climates on this I like the Big Island
has desert yes it has tropical
rainforest it has a volcano its although
every I think it has every weather
climate except Arctic I believe at least
Maui and the Big Island have sort of
every type of climate it's crazy that
just a little bit further down it'll be
different it'll be raining constantly
yeah exactly you just go the other side
and it's completely drying or they have
dwarf trees because they never see the
Sun but then they're you know 200 feet
in the places that it's sunny it's it's
trippy and you could drive around the
whole thing and like how many hours does
it take you to drive around the Big
Island oh the Big Island I don't know
like four hours or something the whole
thing I think so maybe a little more
yeah you like the big island love it
interesting I like Maui you do that's my
favorite every Islands different they're
all their personalities are different
but I like it I mean we've been doing
this for over 23 years when I met Laird
he was big waves sort of come in winter
so when low pressures bring snow like to
the rest of the mainland that low
pressure can also bring big waves and
then my season was summer so we sort of
went back and forth and that's a really
good blend because you you can come to
California and be like oh it's a busy
world I can see a lot of people I can
learn stuff I can do stuff and then I
also makes you appreciate when you go
back to Hawaii you're like clean air
really clean water very beautiful place
some of the ways the ideas about the way
they live there it's it's simple in a
good way I don't mean that in any way
like a derogatory it's like they're not
trying to they're not angling and trying
to get somewhere it's like no we're
living right right
but it can be also very a really hard
place a really hard place how so well I
think you know and you're also talking
about a warrior culture right
Polynesians so you have like this this
very intense love and you know when they
talk about the Aloha spirit generosity
they have like this and then they're
very powerful people as well and
sometimes if they're lit not living as
they're in their most natural way that
they were supposed to and then you
couple it with you know there's not a
ton of opportunities there it's hard to
live there it's far away it's expensive
and and sometimes you know it sounds
cliche but it's like we really do as
human organisms either need to be busy
so like okay working from sunup to
sundown for our food which is how it
used to be and then you're just so tired
you just go to bed and it's pretty
simple and don't let's just survive it
or in the world that we live in now it's
like how do we get people doing things
that are kind of productive and you
think oh I just would sit on the beach
and look at the mountain and it's like
yeah after a while you get bored and if
you're a warrior you're either gonna go
you know do something with that
the
is good for you or you might not so I
think there's there's a lot a lot of
that there I've learned a lot from that
culture but it I mean they're pretty
powerful they're powerful group and you
know it can go the other way pretty
quick where it's you know if there's
drugs and alcohol or you know beefing
and like it's all that so it's if that
was really disturbed when I found out
how much drug abuse there is on some of
the islands yeah crystal meth especially
sad well it's it's again it goes back to
bored I'm like thinking about when your
kids have to stay home for one day you
know you know it's just and now we have
all these the internet and all this
stuff so now you want you sort of think
oh the rest of the world has a perfect
they're all busy and doing fabulous
perfect things and and it's hard like
you got to find people that you're like
let's do something let's go I mean can
you train alone every single time no so
you'd have to have a tribe of people
that are like let's go do this activity
and sometimes they don't it's not that
easy
well so there's there's you say there's
70,000 people on the island on Kauai
yeah Kauai is probably the least
inhabited
it's the oldest island so it has the
most erosion largest beaches and that's
where Larry grew up and it's it's so
really nice the least inhabited of the
islands isn't it well yeah I mean I
don't it's not that I don't count it
yeah I mean of the bigger I run yeah
Molokai man you wouldn't you don't you
don't mess with Molokai no no that's
like that's like you but you got to ask
permission to go hang out over there
really well kinda yeah it's cool though
cuz it's like if you know they'd be like
no you gotta you can't you're out you
gotta go really totally
so is it great it's just the people that
live there you can't like move to
Molokai yeah I mean like you know iid
better has a place on Molokai
yep and it had for many many years but I
think he probably asked if that was
gonna be cool Wow yes interesting yeah
it's and it's beautiful you have some
friends who just went hunting there yeah
beautiful
yeah they're hunted access deer yeah on
Molokai yeah it's a beautiful place and
the people are amazing but you you it's
not like oh I'm just gonna buy a house
there right build a house there's no way
no way no way wow that's interesting all
these different islands have their own
like rules well Neil is you can't even
you can't go there you're not even
allowed to go no I didn't even know that
was an island yeah it's off of course it
again meow meow yeah it's give her that
Oh Jamie's big fan of me ya know it's
all like they probably have you know the
largest percentage of pure of Hawaiians
there hmm so that's cool I mean pretty
that's got to be a great like I found
that like there's a big difference
between the the culture of say Maui
versus the culture of lanai lanai is
more Island D to me whereas Maui seems
like a little bit gentrified well also
the wind because it Maui so windy yes it
brought all the Europeans in the 80s to
windsurf so you're also have not only
mainland us and then Japanese culture
you know 80s
now you're talking about Europeans from
wind and wind surfing so it has a lot
going on
I think Maui it was almost like a
surprise how quick it developed and they
never had a chance to get on top of it
if that makes sense that does make sense
yeah